[Music]
so how long have you lived here at 28
Barbary Lane I moved here in 1966 and I
suppose it was a different place then
but in some ways not at all
[Music]
someone told me I'm hallucinating
because I know this can't be real Mary
Ann singleton returns to Barbary Lane oh
my dear it's more than just an apartment
obviously that's where we go into us
that place saved my life
[Music]
you know it would be alright to have
some feelings about your exchange mom
showing up on a know where she thinks I
am her biological mother
[Music]
and once you feel seen like Ana magical
makes you feel seen you don't want to
leave I don't really know how to
describe it
everything that made me me came from
every land Shawna deserves to know the
truth
sometimes the truth is a burden you have
to carry alone
whenever I look at my mom all I see is
that I wasn't enough to keep her here
obvious to me that you're the center of
this little universe
[Music]
I call them my children
because they are
[Music]
your weapons
[Music]